let's begin with senior foreign affairs
correspondent greg palcott who is live
in la viv ukraine with the very latest
on the ground there greg
hey dan yeah we heard some air raid
sirens about a half an hour ago all's
quiet again here as the russian military
machine grinds on and the ukraine
military does its best to keep them off
in the keyport city of mariopol hundreds
of thousands remain
trapped russian army slamming the city
with artillery shells and bomb strikes
they've been without water food
electricity for many days now
as the noose of the russian military
slowly tightens around the capital of
kiev more ground true is taken
in the
suburb of european troops now within 15
miles victims of the fighting struggling
to get out of it
more and more dan the civilian casualty
tolls are rising as the russians set
aside any kind of precise approach to
fighting basically they're going for the
jugular and here in the western part of
the country the war is coming home
there's a funeral today for soldiers
killed in airstrikes on friday
russians targeting air bases and
military aid convoys there was a huge
outpouring of support tears and anguish
for these lost fighters the refugees are
coming through here too dan now 2.6
million people have left this country
fleeing the ongoing battle back to you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else